ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément en moins de
pannes mais toujours loin de ceux qui
les dirigent leur vie ressemble assez
peu à ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
aujourd'hui nous sommes en haute savoie
dans le pays du mont blanc
[Musique]
predica bonjour ce que fait froid ce
matin
ah oui c'est pas super crack
bon alors toi comment tu t'es tu t'es
retrouvé ici autour de ce lac en fête
est originaire de la région non moi je
suis du sud lance du pas de calais je
suis arrivé ici pour ce qui est bon il
ya de la viande acquis bord ça s'est mal
passé voilà puis bon comme je n'avais
plus envie j'ai fait le tour de la bahia
pas de travail stricte l'arrivée ici
comme tous les étés confinement et a pas
de famille
si l'un d'entre eux c'est à des enfants
j'ai beau mec sait pas mais j'ai trois
enfants qui sont déjà 12 14 et le
premier voire 17 ans le mois de mars
ça fait 4 4 ou 5 ans que je n'ai pas vu
ah oui tu vois plus en plus tombées non
tu faisais quoi comme boulot je
travaille en fonderie comme j'ai
travaillé ce désir et des chaînes de
montage souvent c'est sa préparation de
commandes il ya aussi dans le bâtiment
pourquoi tu as choisi précisément ce
lieu j'ai vu que vous en faites la
région était dynamique et terry j'ai
même lu que une région comme la savoie
et la haute-savoie avait à peu près le
même pib qui est monaco d'un mois je me
suis dit qui dit je vais trouver une âme
isme richesse boulot c'est obligé et si
en plus il ya deux saisons
ils ont la saison d'hiver la saison
d'été donc je me suis dit que tisser
l'hiver l'hiver en montagne l'été dans
la vallée il y avait toujours toujours
toujours toujours de quoi faire khl mais
en fait ben là c'est pas le cas
ce qui arrive est ici tap-tap lente et
attentes autour du lac voilà et j'avais
pas une tente au début je suis venu et
qui dorment en sac de couchage il
faisait encore la lire et à la rigueur
le tüv elle était même sous quoi
aux yeux des meneurs je suis pas non
plus dans la ville même à dormir sur le
trottoir complicité de plus agréable
mais seulement voilà qu'au film on a
fait que main
c'est un petit peu dérapé quoi c'était
pas c'était pas le but premier
à 40 ans on se dit pas ouais j'ai un pro
du travail et au final on se retrouve
sdf soro kazié travail à vivre des aides
sociales et ou non c'est pas c'est pas
tonton et écoles du problème les gens
qui t'ont vu ici on dit oh là là mais il
faut pas qu'il reste la belle étoile
faut que je dise merci c'est
l'association jules ferry en fait
l'association quitte à eux et a
découvert en quelques emplettes voilà
qui est venu vers toi voilà qui sont
venus vers moi tu va le monter où tu tu
habites ouais bon allez chez toi vu que
ça a l'air d'un ouvrier classé divers
donc on y croisera peut-être pas grand
monde n'ont pu y croiser quelqu'un ça
moi je vais vous faire voir qu'on m'a
prêté que ce qu'on m'a prêté
gracieusement peu propos est dehors
c'est pas c'est pas fou ça doit faire
quoi à peine 10 mètres carrés mais au
moins je suis pas dehors
voilà c'est là c'est un minimum et cela
que tu vie quoi c'est là que je suis
c'est pas grand c'est pas folichon
messieurs l'abri et c'est ça le plus
important
atari va faire ta popote plaque
chauffante un micro-ondes j'ai mon café
voilà avec un petit peu de bonne volonté
et des gens qu'ils ont quand un peu
d'humanité
donc c'est ton vélo là c'est mon vélo
c'est que 22 gars de l'association jules
ferry qui me il m'a donné la donné lui
s'en servent épaules en avait un autre
et comme ici à pied c'est difficile
moyen de locomotion mois transports
transports en commun sont quasi
inexistants ici nous on n'est pas loin
de megève
non non non à quoi dix minutes un quart
d'heure à peu près à mes doigts en pavés
locaux n'ont pas vélo en ville où se
seraient pas serait pas jouable en vélo
c'est pas tant à megève
il y à des constructions il ya des corps
sociaux
et concitoyens pacs et du coup mais non
on va les voir un monsieur encore un
petit peu les chantiers etc
c'est carrément un autre monde là on est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure on
arrivait dans un petit monaco local du
rox et gadea juste à voir les gens dans
la voiture comment ils soient habillés
avec leurs petits chapeaux leurs petits
trucs tu les quatre épingles série kings
qui te regardent comme ça c'est ça c'est
le royaume des inégalités sociales
flagrante
il ya nous il ya eu il ya des chantiers
partout ya des chantiers partout l'a
déjà vu en arrivant même là à mon avis
c'est bête à dire mais ça doit pas de
l'entreprise française aussi des
travailleurs détachés qui travaillent le
samedi on sait c'est pas secret pour
personne le peu que j'ai travaillé ici
j'ai bien vu qu'il y avait beaucoup de
briller d'état c'est ici ici ils
viennent ils doublent leurs salaires par
rapport à leur pays c'est europe dont on
veut même pas peut-être que j'en fais
autant
[Musique]
tu es inscrit dans les agences d'intérim
toutes les agences et les agences et
donc tu as donné ton dossier etc est
décédé j'en ai remis à jour les
améliorer j'ai donc là ça marche pas
terrible ça marche pas terrible document
serge mais je me laisse pas le choix tu
es le rsa vu que je travaille j'ai
travaillé entre deux et que c'est que
j'ai pas assez d'heures pour le pôle
emploi t on peut entre les deux systèmes
entre les deux systèmes rsa complet
gênant ce mois ci la caf ont versé 147
euros
d'accord et le mois dernier j'ai
travaillé trois jours donc ça me perd
200 euros donc ça fait que je vais vivre
avec 350 euros pour le mois alors quand
on entend les politiciens dire à la télé
pas travailler pour gagner plus
ben oui mais dans des chefs comme ça
sinon tu travailles pour gagner moins ou
être perdants après on va dire les gens
sont pas motivés c'est facile de dire ça
quand organes 5000 6000 euros par mois
tout joueur mais vous connaissez les
personnes qui gagnent un smig
ils doivent tous payer le reste qu à la
fin encore moins qu'un quelqu'un qui
aurait le et raison parce qu'au final
quand tu as le rsa ont répété frais
médicaux hop et les trois quarts de son
loyer
excusez ma pression mais on va fabriquer
des assistés après moi j'ai pas cette
mentalité là j'ai pas été élevé comme ça
mon grand père est un ancien mineur il
descendait au fond il savait pas si ray
revoir leur famille ils sont mort est
mon grand père je les ai vus mourir en
fait parce que ses poumons s'était
rempli clairement donc moi je me dis
qu'à la rigueur j'ai pigé pas le droit
de me plaindre si tu avais un souhait
pour la france idéale revoir tout le
système revoir tout le système tout ce
qui est tout ce qui va avec
c'était coluche qui disait ça qu'on lui
devait au moins 30 autres davance la
france c'est comme une pyramide il y en
a un couteau et lui il est tout en haut
c'est le roi et en bas ben on est plein
mais on est à même le sol dans la merde
donc l'iccat si on va faire la photo
mathemagie juste devant le panneau parce
que je trouve ça intéressant tu as tu
veux rester la tête hors de l'eau
voilà vas-y recul un petit peu tu vois
tu me regardes
[Musique]